being a convincing actor is about more
than just crying on cue and perfecting
your angry stares actors also need to be
trained to speak with foreign accents
for many of their roles whether it's to
conceal their own native tongue or to
convince audiences they hail from a
whole different home front in the case
of these Hollywood stars their dialect
coaches must have left something to be
desired because they're terrible
on-screen accents will probably never
disappear from their blooper reels
Gerard Butler he may have been born and
raised in Scotland but Gerard Butler
doesn't get to play Scottish characters
as often as he might like which means
there are many examples of him
attempting to sound American
and failing spectacularly perhaps no
effort has been quite as tragic as
2010's the bounty hunter in which he has
the darndest time trying to make use of
his hundreds of dialect sessions and
what I do as I hunt down criminals
idiots who jump bail specifically oddly
enough his Irish accent and PS I love
you isn't much better either I would
like to apologize to the nation of
Ireland for completely abusing an accent
Keanu Reeves there's one thing Keanu
Reeves can do better than anyone in the
entire acting business
[Music]
Wow but playing a Brit is just not in
his skill set he proved as much when he
starred in Bram Stoker's Dracula and
made everyone laugh for all the wrong
reasons with his faux English
affectation I've seen many strange
things already bloody wolves chasing me
through some blue inferno director
Francis Ford Coppola later blamed
himself for the famously poor
performance in the 1992 drama telling
Entertainment Weekly we knew that it was
tough for him to affect an English
accent he tried so hard that was the
problem actually he wanted to do it
perfectly and in trying to do it
perfectly it came off as stilted it
definitely says something that he was
able to upstage that hairdo yes sir I
won't give it my full attention John
Malkovich if you're going to put on a
Russian accent
at least try not to sound like a KGB
cartoon that's the lesson John Malkovich
apparently did not learn before he
became a Soviet gangster in rounders the
outrageous accent is not only extra
Flemmi but it borders on the insane paid
that's men his money apparently even
Malkovich knew he wasn't delivering a
quality depiction there because co-star
Matt Damon later revealed and he looks
at me because I'm a terrible actor but
hey at least we got this Damon is amout
of the deal if you don't pay my money
then you fine Brad Pitt an Irish accent
is incredibly difficult to fake and Brad
Pitt knows all about that the actor
trained with a dialect coach to get his
dialect down pat well accents never been
my strong point so it was uh put a lot
of work into it but in the devil zone
the Hollywood heartthrob failed to
present that patented Irish lilt the
meat looks delicious what is it it's
corned beef and cabbage I thought that's
all you ate over there hey at least he
knows how to speak Italian in a pinch
grazie Kevin Costner
Robin Hood Prince of Thieves wasn't
exactly a critical darling and it hasn't
really stood the test of time with
audiences either but Kevin Costner's
terrible take on a British accent in the
movie is still absolutely unforgettable
if I must I will take you a piece of the
time Hey it may have not even been a
British accent for all we know because
he sounds more like a West Coast dude
indulging in the Southern California Sun
than a man rummaging through the forests
of Nottingham except he's totally
supposed to be English
this is English courage Cameron Diaz
Gangs of New York is a beautiful film
anchored by one heck of a performance
from Daniel day-lewis but there's no
question that Cameron Diaz's terrible
accent tends to take you out of it while
there are moments in the 2002 film when
leading man Leonardo DiCaprio also seems
to forget to flip his accents which he
as rarely turns hers on and when she
does it's not good
oh ain't started working yet not only
does she not sound Irish but she doesn't
sound like she's from 1863 either maybe
when you're aiming a little straighter
Angelina Jolie there are a lot of
terrible aspects of Oliver Stone's
Alexander but Angelina Jolie's wacky
accent is one of the most bizarre
elements of the whole movie oh no he's
accentuating to be fair to her Colin
Farrell decided to keep his native Irish
tongue while starring as the title Greek
Conqueror and Val Kilmer and Jared Leto
also followed suit for some strange
reason so that left Jolie all by her
lonesome trying to bring some Macedonian
realness to her portrayal of Olympia but
she sounds more like a Russian mafioso
than the real deal Jolie might have
proven herself as having a healthy
dialect spread with her British tones in
Tomb Raider and her French Cuban prose
and a mighty heart but this is one flub
that won't soon be forgotten
would give me thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel let's check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]
[Applause]
you